And I think that the right to abortion
must be 1 invalidable right,
must be 1 right that applies to everyone and everywhere.
I greet uh.
The decision made by the government uh
French a few years ago
to have gone from 12 to 14 weeks,
here it is good,
it should,
it should be what is the norl,
I think on a European scale.
Now I think it takes
to make this right inanimable,
It is accompanied by average,
uh.
And I'm scared
to see that the right to abortion
is going backwards today in your country,
retreats. In fact
I'm scared to see that uh.
Our loss of sovereignty
industrialist,
especially in terms of drug production
had consequences,
1 Method of gathering important pills
uh last March
which resulted in 1 new
immobilization brake.
And so if I want us to reaffirm with strength
straight, inalinable,
it means certainly,
you will have said it
in our constitution,
but also behind
accompanied by the necessary means
to allow this right to apply
throughout the country,
everywhere in Europe,
but also everywhere on the French territory